hey guys it's dense defender thing Kara
and I'm David Griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of x-men days of future
past the second trailer that just came
out what did you think well I have to I
guess quote you on AMC movie talk
yesterday you use the word potential yes
and I think that's a perfect way of
describing this trailer it's an amazing
trailer first of all looks great the
flow I mean like any great action movie
the best thing you can do is just stack
the deck with incredible actors that's
what this movie is done but like you
said this could be great this could be
maybe one of the better superhero movies
ever made but it might not be depends
how they pull up until the script Bryan
Singer's taking the helm again so it
looks like everything's in place for
this to be amazed and that's my first
impression but again like you said we'll
have to see yeah the keyword potential
doesn't mean when the movie comes out
it's gonna be the greatest thing ever
I'm saying based on the first trailer
which was awesome in this second trailer
which is also awesome yeah in just the
the history of this this storyline you
know this is kind of one of the more
revered story lines of the x-men
universe it's actually not a very long
story line in the comics yeah there's a
few issue two or three two issues they
also had tackled it in the cartoon
series 90s they kind of stressed that
one out a little bit longer and and so
this is the the movie version okay so
it's not a Shadowcat / kitty pryde as
the main character but of course they
were I've seen some complaints about you
know this like oh they changed it it's
that's why it sucks you know mister I'm
sorry right like listen I I'm a fan of
this stuff but I'm don't consider like
this kind of extreme fanboyism we're
like you change something and it's like
oh cuz I've read people talk oh the
magneto costumes wrong or this costume
is wrong or did it is not like it's in
the car which I don't get cuz every if
you're if you are a fan of comics you
know they change things all the time
they rewrite history like if you're in
the Ultimate Universe they killed Peter
Parker there's a black spider-man now I
mean stuff changes all the time there's
no such thing in comic books as
continuity it does exist for a time DC
is going to relaunch everything I mean
so they can they change
things was another complaint everybody's
like oh the the Sentinels look different
it'll go to do in this series I'm like
the settlers were created I mean I guess
we could say this now decades ago it's
been you know years since then
perceptions of artificial intelligence
of robots views change watch alien the
first movie and look at the cockpit
watch prometheus and look at the cockpit
why would you have a big chunky
supercomputer you can have something
sleek and it looks like it moves better
i mean like technology changes it's not
going to look like it did in the 80s I
think the essence of the sentinel still
remain they are smaller right sure how
they were the AMA crook but I think the
design elements still you know resemble
what the Sentinels were and I thought
one of the best shots was in the
beginning of the trailer where you have
those hundreds of cells oh yeah and I
like this kind of parallel storyline I
mean they had that in the in the comic
book storyline but not to this extent no
it was just kitty pryde going back and
forth and seeing what was going on in
the present day what's going on in the
future right this one is actually more
of the instead of I don't know how much
present-day stuff there is yeah but it
looks more like the 70s the past and
then the few yeah there's probably a
little bit of present-day stuff but it's
mostly the future and in the past and
the 70s you know it's a tune to people
who are a little bit hesitant maybe
friends of the collar sorry uh fans fans
of the comics who are super loyal to is
to give the movie a chance you know let
these actors to do such a great job in
Fassbender and James McAvoy as Professor
X and Magneto just torn up lasting it
it's such a good movie wasn't perfect it
was not perfect but they did such a good
job like try to appreciate them film as
a film whether it follows the comic book
exactly or not like let the movie work
as itself I don't tie it down to
mythology and lore and it has to stick
to that like this is somebody's
interpretation of a story and of course
they're gonna revolve it on Wolverine
he's the popular character in the x-men
franchise like the new poster new
posters heavily featured it's Jennifer
Lawrence and it's Hugh Jackman and this
is just marketing Jennifer Lawrence is
hot right now she's huge she's got you
know Hunger Games got all these things
ago when she first did first class she
wasn't that big no and now it's the
reason why
turn hugh jackman even though it is
supposed to be kitty pryde story it sits
at her store in the comic books you know
I'm sorry but she's you know not as
marketable as Hugh Jackman Hugh Jackman
is the house I can tell my mom hey I'm
once you do with Hugh Jackman and she'll
know who that is whether she knows who
Wolverine is or not she's going to who
that is also Jennifer Lawrence it's just
it's marketing that's Hollywood this is
the way things work you know so I'm
super excited i like i love this trailer
i think one of the best we've seen all
year look in the movies coming up pretty
soon may is not that it's not that far
off and then I'm sure it's gonna lead
into Xmen apocalypse which they've been
hinting at all right maybe a third
Wolverine movie hugh jackman said he'll
he'll do another one if the script is
right I don't think you signed on but he
said I think he's pretty close to
signing now yeah what I've heard because
i think i think mangold is coming back
yeah who i thought did a really good job
with the lace lastly yeah so I I think
that's gonna get and they already have a
set date for it so right i think that's
pretty close to being done right alright
but alright guys so that's what we
thought of the trailer you can let us
know what you think you post your
comments below on the website to cure
calm or on our youtube channel thank
aeropro make sure to subscribe to that
where we can find us on twitter you know
let Dennis and I know if you're you know
if you're hesitant about the movie if
you're excited if you're you look at the
comics better or you just don't really
care either way find out let us know at
think hero i'm at griffin de and we also
have a Facebook page that's facebook.com
slash think hero fans make sure to LIKE
that page and share our videos on
Twitter Facebook and other social media
you